madame monsieur bonsoir on peut sans
doute parler de miracle douze personnes
ont été retrouvées saines et sauves hier
soir sous les décombres de deux chalets
enseveli sous 1 8 mètre de neige
à la suite d'une gigantesque avalanche
cela dans le hameau de peisey-nancroix
en savoie caroline audrin fini le
cauchemar fine il angoisse jamais ils
ouvriront le sourire de leurs sauveteurs
depuis le début de l'après midi 150
personnes ont sondé la neige
équipé de longues tiges mécanique au
coude à coude ils ont fouillé une masse
neigeuse de huit mètres de profondeur
dans ce mur de glace aussi dur que du
béton ils ont retrouvé douze personnes
ensevelies dans trois chalets différents
les derniers ont pu être dégagés à 21h
après être resté plus de huit heures
prisonniers des débris de leur chalet
laval ont fait leur colère la maison et
on entende à craquer ça allait casser ça
va être plus qu'assez rideau puis les
chambres côté wild était complètement
écrasée fait alors on a creusé un trou
dans le plancher
et puis on allait dans laquelle on se
fait peur l'avalanche s'est déclenchée
en début d'après-midi à 3000 m
d'altitude et pendant 2 km elle a tout
détruit sur son passage
elle est arrivée matt est sourde dira un
témoin elle a tout enseveli en quelques
secondes et c'est grâce au témoignage
d'un habitant de peser que les secours
ont pu être dirigés vers les chats les
habiter au total ce sont huit maisons
anciennes qui ont été englouti des
maisons de pierre couverte de lauzes
certaines dataient de 300 ans
bien à l'abri des couloirs d'avalanche
traditionnels